Whether you're watching Netflix in one session,
Or play the new Zelda game from start to finish,
Most of us spend long hours in front of screens.
But do you see these bad for your mind and your body?
In the past, it could have been fatal indeed!
In 1967 a manufacturing error led to the sale of televisions
Sends harmful X-rays with a radiation rate greater than 100,000 times
What is safe today.
But even modern TVs cause stress to your eyes
Under normal conditions, the human eye is sprayed about 18 times per minute
But when you put them in front of the screens, this rate is severely reduced
Causing tired and burning eyes.
Unfortunately these symptoms are short term in general.
Children who spend long hours at home can have advanced effects
From the short-sighted state where the eye can not focus properly,
We see it more often in children who spend a lot of time indoors,
So not because you have to focus on close-up devices and vice versa,
You do not see landscapes and spacious spaces.
But scientists think that the sun itself may play a role in eye health,
While television feels that it is a good way to comfort the body and brain,
But it is not always good, not just because it is a lifestyle
Contributes to weight gain,
Studies have shown that people who do not watch television often burn more calories
Even if they did not perform many physical activities.
They simply do more mental activities such as reading or playing chess,
Or some home tasks that require more energy and burn more calories,
If you want to relax, watching TV before bedtime is also harmful to you.
Studies have shown that they reduce normal sleep hours
Causing insomnia.
It also affects pre-sleep activities.
The researchers found that people watching television more than 20 hours a week
Their sperm count decreases by 44%.
The most prominent results are directly related to the life span.
Not only because there is a close relationship between TV viewing time and the risks of obesity and heart disease,
But the shock is that several studies have found a relationship between TV viewing time
And all causes leading to death.
A study found that every hour you spend in front of the TV decreases 22 minutes of your life,
Of course, the relationship is not the same.
You can have a healthy relationship with television
If you use it properly like anything else.
The origin of many of these claims is the association of physical activity with television viewing hours.
The sooner I move the longer I live.
Translation: team translate @autrjim